es el momento de actualizar la
información económica de france 24 con
jorge hurtado jorge regresó con usted
porque argentina después de un día de
protestas y después de superar una
crisis gubernamental aprobó el aumento
del salario mínimo así desde el gobierno
de ese país junto a empresarios y
sindicatos acordaron aumentar el salario
mínimo por segunda vez en el año según
informó el ministerio del trabajo el
consejo del salario acordó que el alza
del 35 por ciento aprobado en abril se
aplicaba progresivamente hasta febrero
del 2022 y se eleve hasta el 52,7 por
ciento el nuevo monto del salario mínimo
queda de todas formas por debajo del
valor actual de la canasta básica de los
argentinos la inflación en argentina
superó el 50 por ciento en los últimos
12 meses del año y esto dijeron los
argentinos que salieron a protestar a
las calles del día de hoy
para intentar aplicar un fuerte ajuste
para poder garantizar los acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional y el nuevo
gabinete hace honor justamente a esto
porque en vez de discutir cómo
solucionar los problemas estructurales
del país que fue el cachetazo que busque
ese recibió el gobierno en las
elecciones lo que hacen es un gabinete a
la derecha completamente
cuando probaron la primera elsa en abril
de este año el salario mínimo se
esperaba que la inflación no pasara del
30% y ahora pues ya se conoce que esa
cifra fue superada y ello le sumó que un
gabinete además criticado porque se
caracteriza por la ausencia de mujeres
vamos a pasar a venezuela se conocieron
datos de la economía en ese país la
actividad económica y reflejó una
contracción del 28 por ciento en el
primer semestre del 2021 según el
independiente observatorio venezolano de
finanzas
el indicador de este organismo registra
las actividades relacionadas al sector
petrolero financiero y de gobierno esta
estimación no oficial apunta a que la
mayor contracción se anotó en el sector
público con menos 82 por ciento seguido
del final con menos 55% y el petrolero
que repuntó casi 3% el estudio si todo
el índice mensual de actividad económica
y asegura que todos los sectores
confirman su indicador según ellos las
pérdidas en la banca se asocian a la
política de encaje bancario que ha
limitado el crédito evitando financiar
otros sectores 'venezuela angela no
actualiza sus datos macroeconómicos
desde 2014 pero según este estudio el
producto interno bruto de ese país
perdió más del 80 por ciento de su valor
respecto a lo que tenían en 2012 bueno
jorge y cómo le va al salvador con el
bitcoin es cuál es la noticia bueno el
país centroamericano aprovecho la bajada
del precio del beat coin tras el miedo
por la quiebra del gigante chino
inmobiliario evergrande el presidente de
ese país nadie buque le anunció la
compra de 150 bitcoin adicionales que
sumado a los que ya tenían eleva su
posesión en total en cripto monedas a
700 tomando en cuenta el valor actual
del bitcoin el salvador ha invertido 31
millones de dólares en cripto activos el
bitcoin registró pérdidas del 11 por
ciento en los últimos días y se cotiza
en los 41 dólares todo después de una
recuperación hace unos meses que llevó
su precio hasta 50 mil dólares varios
organismos como el banco mundial o el
fondo monetario internacional han
mostrado su preocupación por esta
aventura que llevó al salvador a
convertirse en el primer país del mundo
en oficializar el bitcoin como moneda en
curso legal y lejos de américa latina'
en afganistán a ella y nuevos miembros
del gabinete económico del recién
nombrado gobierno talibán así es el
grupo talibán en el poder como sabrá
desde mediados de agosto de este año
presentó a un ministro de comercio de
los diputados que intentan revivir el
sistema financiero de ese país noordin
así si un empresario de panshir fue
nombrado ministro interino de comercio y
de industria y se sumará al equipo del
ministerio de finanzas para apoyar
también al ministerio de asuntos
económicos los funcionarios deberán
enfrentar una profunda crisis económica
y el bloqueo de la ayuda internacional
principal motor del producto interno
bruto de afganistán actualmente unos 4
millones de afganos enfrentan una crisis
alimentaria según naciones unidas la
sequía que afecta a 25 de las 34
provincias agrava la situación para el
70% de los afganos
y para nuestros televidentes los
indicadores de la jornada pero wall
street cerró mixto este jueves a la
espera de la reunión de la reserva
federal que concluye mañana y en
latinoamérica también calmaron los
nervios respecto a la crisis del impacto
en el sector inmobiliario chino aunque
hay que esperar el jueves cuando
sabremos si e brand logrará pagar los
intereses de su millonaria deuda bueno
jorge y cuál es su cifra del día la
cifra del día angela es 27 billones de
dólares en pérdidas anuales se evitaría
el mundo si protege el medio ambiente lo
dice el banco mundial en un informe
donde asegura que el cambio climático no
sólo es un asunto ambiental sino también
económico gracias a ustedes jorge y a
nuestros televidentes llegan en france
[Música]
i